[Music]
they will kill you hey which character
should we have narrate this stupid
exposition opening densha guess i mean
she's got the most credibility story
about Riddick and he narrated the first
movie and even there it's part of this
movie later but half alive and half
something else
dead right I bet he's half dead if
there's such a thing as discount Ron
Perlman
here's discount Ron Perlman there's not
one single practical reason for the ship
designed to have the artillery guys
dangling from a line outside the ship
with the phrase what the grab a gat oh
come on
future space bounty hunters call guns
GATS are there from the space hood it's
about you oh my head 101.5
why would you lie about the bounty know
that come from me see now Riddick is
narrating how many narrators does this
movie have so well since you're asking I
can basically guarantee you're gonna run
into her at some point whoever she is
this planet has a terrible PR department
these guards go through all these safety
measures and then just leave the cage
door wide open plenty long enough for a
rabid woman to jump out and bite a leg
or something rabid animal girl also
happens to be hot cliche they say most
of your brain sets down in cryosleep
Riddick repeats cryo sleep speech from
the first movie with an echo as helium
prime ever heard of redundancy you have
at least one maybe two other ships that
can help out in case an intruder does
something like this also this move
should have damaged Riddick ship as much
as the other guys and there's nothing
around this statue this guy's been
telling the story for years to get
chicks into bed Julian Prime shares his
sunlight with all worlds nearby how do
you live on a planet that can provide
that much sunlight to multiple worlds
the HVAC bill on this planet must be
insane you will leave us to our fate
just like you did her first Riddick when
he's in the ship and now here can
someone just call this woman by name
already it's so cool that Riddick can
see everything and these guys can't you
know who else can't us and thank you for
the rapid-fire editing and total
darkness asshole
and her yeah still looking for a name
you know what would make this space
battle better somebody named wedge or
red leader well you know characters or
perspective I'm so massively confused at
this point I can barely make a comment
but the guys with guns can't seem to hit
any of the guys who are just carrying
clubs until they're three inches away
remember your place de Vaca my place is
at your side dear husband I sure am glad
these characters cleared up the
relationship and remembered each other's
names right after that huge battle there
is another vez Batman's dad uses slang
to shorten universe to verse ripping off
Firefly in the process and I'll take
your soul is mine okay am I totally
religious person and that looked
extremely evil but sure I'll become one
of you now wait just a damn minute what
was Riddick's plan when he came in here
killed their best guy and then profits
if it isn't for damn Vaako Riddick gets
slaughtered the end I'll be a CG
spinning blade it's been a long time
since I smelled beautiful you must not
be washing with Herbal Essences then the
reader that's a weird way to say his
name since these quasi Dead's read
thoughts and memories does Riddick refer
to himself as the Riddick this part of
the conversation Riddick had with Aryan
didn't happens
Furion sounds racist like the people of
their race identified themselves with
Furies so much that they call themselves
Furion is that like calling white people
keniji shion's kill the Riddick why does
he let Riddick out of the purple holding
energy thing to fight the guards that he
just ordered to kill Riddick
just my dick when you get the chance I
dusted my dick once for fingerprints
premature Riddick is being sent to the
one prison in the verse that just so
happens to be holding hot Jack his back
of the bus still a common reference in
space future this thing looks awesome ly
futuristic but wouldn't a computer
monitor do the job better than some
liquid hologram but why does only Lord
Vaco have a wife where are all the other
Necromonger wives why to Necromongers
even care about love or feelings aren't
they mongers of necro like death like
shouldn't they be gorging out on death
and decay like 99% of the time they're
not Village
wife abuse turns to sexy time cliche is
such great missing you
looks like you're about to have
greatness in you you know they say in
cryo sleep bath scene hints at a lap
dance but turns into leg wrestling just
in case you confused it with Crematory
of Japan I own this place
also this planet has a terrible pee oh I
already said that approach this is the
least useful navigation computer ever
it's like the magic 8-ball of navigation
devices are we headed in the right
direction outlook not good yeah I sure
am glad they solve that not good angle
of approach somehow without showing us
this is sneak well if you want to be
protesting about it now I prefer calling
Andy Riddick the last time we visited
crematoria we saw jack being sent to
prison and putting some kind of kennel
or something
now Riddick is being dropped directly
into the prison like this is protocol
and no one appears to be in little cages
Riddick does cirque de soleil I'll run
the numbers again it takes a couple of
days the problem went running the
numbers is something that should take
roughly 10 minutes at most
especially in space future a young
warrior once consulted a seer Oh a
prediction as one of these prophecies
ever been wrong in a movie like this
character wakes up when his name is
whispered from a great distance cliche
all right look we dusted our tracks that
the same as dusting your dick
I don't get the impression Riddick is
great at escaping prison so much as I
get the impression the writers are just
really good at giving inconvenient
boosts all the time it's gonna be one
speed mine if you can't keep up don't
step up here just die so I guess all
these people are dead then I mean you've
barely started and not a single one of
them is going at riddick speed okay so
Riddick reaches the top of the cliff
thingy and sees the hangar and then he
turns around to look at the sunrise and
yells for Kira to move her ass but then
suddenly after he pulls the other
prisoner dudes up none of them are at
the top somehow also excruciating heat
can't affect you as long as you're
behind a rock ah the deadly sunrise
explosion ends just at the edge of the
cliff they just reached the top of
there's no way those flames would ever
reach past that point at all seriously a
Furion ghost just comes out of nowhere
to give Riddick powers geez I guess this
heat isn't really all that bad I mean
why did we even care if the light hit
them how was the planet like 900 degrees
at this point but just inside this
little cave it's totally room
temperature stay away from him
and in return you'll be hunted no more
what's the purpose of not killing
Riddick why would you even propose a
deal like this there's only one guy who
can hurt you and you're making a deal
with him that's the fucking point
see this guy walks 15 steps and goes
from totally alive to toast
I'm calling bolt on this planet and it's
bull physics that only work when they
don't interfere with the story how is he
able to just fly the ship out of the
hangar anyway when earlier we saw that
the ship had to be super careful not to
fly in the daylight burning portion of
life not get caught in the Sun this is a
day of days well sure I mean is that
literal there's this one of those month
of Sundays kind of thing did you reach
the underverse this guy misses the most
obvious double meaning ever
how can an elemental who can turn
herself into wind not get out of this
prisoner cave or whatever she's in this
can still be a day of days every day is
a day of damn days this lens of dead
did you also find the guy who was right
next to him he won't escape twice
he's already escaped like hundreds and
hundreds of times it's what he does
poison heroine leaves the picture even
though you know she's coming back to
save the hero cliche
you know what Riddick could use right
now a Furion ghost who just blows away
all the bad guys for oh sure let's let
our prisoner the elemental out of her
cell to watch the big showdown with
Riddick and Lord what's his pants crying
a single tear after death cliche
ooh cute girl main character has to
explain the very obvious reason all the
necros start bowing to it this movie
somehow got a director's cut
[Music]
you
hard-pressed to make it back
what is he doing he's beginning to be
hey the best song in the world or I'll
eat yourself
[Music]